بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اعلن على بركه
الله
افتتاح اعمال اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه
التحضيري للقمه الدول العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثون
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على خاتم الانبياء والمرسلين مع رئيس
الدوره المجلس الجامعه المبكره اصحاب
السنون وزراء الخارجيه معالي الامين العام
الجامع الدول العربيه حضور الكريم السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يطيب لي في مستحيل هذا الاجتماع ان ارحب
بكم في بلدكم الثاني من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
راجيا من المولى جل وعلا ان يكلل جهودنا
بالتوفيق والنجاح كما تقدموا بالشكر
والتقدير للجمهوريه الجزائر الديمقراطيه
الشعبيه على جهودها خلال فتره رئاستها من
القمه السابقه وانتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب
بمشاركه الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في
اجتماعنا اليوم اصحاب السوء والمعاني يمر
عالمنا اليوم بتحديات وصعوبات عديده
تجعلنا امام مفترق طرق تحتم علينا الوقوف
صفا واحدا وبذل المزيد من الجهد لتعزيز
العمل العربي المشترك من اجل مواجهتها
وايجاد الحلول المناسبه لها لتصبح منطقتنا
امنه ومستقره
بالخير والرفاه ان منطقه العربيه تسخر
بطاقات بشريه وثروات طبيعيه تجعلنا امام
تحدي مع انفسنا يفرض علينا جميعا التنسيق
المستمر وتسخير كافه الادوات الممكنه
وتفعيل الابتكار الات عمل الجديده نابدين
خلافه البينيه رافضين التدخلات الخارجيه
واضعين نصب اعيننا مصالح دولنا وشعوبنا من
اجل تحقيق نهضه شامله طالما تطلعت اليها
شعوبنا
في الختام تجدد المملكه تتطلعها للعمل
معكم جميعا لتعزيز استطرار
والامكانات للمدن قدما في مسار التنميه
والازدهار في بناء مستقبل تنعم بها
اجيالنا القادمه وندعو الى القدير بان
نحقق تحققت قمه جده التطلعات المرجوه منها
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات